[MUSIC PLAYING]
INES ENVID: Thank you so much.
Thank you for sharing your
valuable time with us.
It means a lot.
My name Ines Envid.
I'm a product manager with
Google Cloud in networking.
And I will be sharing the stage
with Yuri and with Vineet.
So we wanted to spend
some time in this Next
to share with you what are
the progresses that we've
made in terms of network
telemetry and security
telemetry and give
you an overview on how
you as a customer
or as a partner
can utilize the
visibility tools that we
are providing with the cloud.
So as you are moving or
[INAUDIBLE] customer are moving
more of your deployments and
applications to the cloud,
you are relying on us to--
as a platform-- to provide
with infrastructure
that provides you with
the underlying networking
within underlying capabilities.
That comes with obviously
a lot of responsibility.
We need to provide you
with the same visibility
as you're having for your data
center deployments so that you
can understand the
signals that are
meaningful for your deployments
and for your applications.
And then you can take
actions based on that.
So in order to provide
the visibility,
it is important that we are
giving you with information
either to validate that the
intent of your deployment
so that you know
that the latency--
the throughput, the
patterns of your network--
are matching your intention.
Or we need to give
you the signals
to alert or notify of potential
deviation of that intention.
And how are we doing that?
We as a platform are able to
provide the networking signals,
some visibility at the scale.
We are providing the visibility
without taking up performance
impacting your applications.
And we're also providing
near real-time capability
so that you can
actually see what's
happening in your network
almost at the same time
that it's happen.
I'll go into more
details on how is that.
So for us as a platform we
are treating really network
telemetry and security telemetry
similarly as a big data
problem.
We are able to scale
our infrastructure
to provide you that
visibility without you
having to worry about what it
means to your applications.
But also we are ingesting
the data in our, for example,
BigQuery for big
data processing.
And the volumes that we are
generating, we are in real time
being able to export to either
your partner tools or BigQuery
or Pub/Sub streaming
so that you can
integrate with the best way
for you to extract the signals.
We are adding the capabilities
of the telemetry at every path.
I'll go in detail on
what those paths are
and what exactly looks like.
But you can see the
signals for traffic
that is from your public facing
applications from the internet.
If they are sitting
behind a load balancer,
you will get telemetry
associated to that.
You also can see the traffic
that is in and out every VM
instance or GKE deployment.
And you can as well
see the traffic
that it goes back
and forth from a word
VM instances to the
Google managed services,
for example, storage
or big data analytics
like BigQuery or Bigtable.
So basically
everything that it's
in and out our
infrastructure that we'll
be able to visualize.
So let's go exactly on
what are the capabilities.
So as I said, we are
uniquely positioned
to provide this scale and the
near real-time capabilities
for your deployments.
And this is something that we
are very proud of, the fact
that we are able to provide
you with aggregation
of the flows that are
going on in our network
for your deployments
aggregated at five seconds.
So you will see
an aggregated set
of logs every five seconds,
which is, again, almost near
real time.
We will do that at a scale.
So you don't really
need to worry
about what the throughput
is to your application
or how much data
you are generating.
We are able to perform
the telemetry of those
without taking any impact
on your applications.
And on top of that,
we as well add
in annotations to those traffic
flows where it is meaningful.
Like, for example, if there
is a flow from traffic
from or to the internet, then
we are adding annotations
from the autonomous
system number or the yield
location of the public IP.
So then when you are actually
getting the information
you not only get
the five [INAUDIBLE]
and what the actual flow
look like but you also
see annotations that
we as a platform
are able to add in
those logs so that you
can have more
information that might
be meaningful for those
specific traffic paths.
All right.
So which are the user
genres that we are
targeting with our products?
So network diagnostics--
so that you
can have an correlation of what
is your application performance
and what is the underlying
performance of your network.
So for example, you might
be interested in what
is the specific latency, RTT,
or the throughput generated
by a specific application.
Or you might be
actually interested
in diagnosing why traffic
might be succeeding or failing
from or to a VM instance.
So you're able to go to the
fine-grained granularity
of a specific endpoint,
filter into a specific IP,
and get the metrics,
latency, RTT, throughput that
are associated to that.
We're also going
to allow you to see
whether a specific connection
was allowed or denied
by a firewall rule to see
if a specific connection
from an application
succeed or fail and why.
We're as well
targeting network usage
and planning so that
you can actually
validate that the
patterns in your network
are according to
what you will expect.
So if you-- instead
of [INAUDIBLE]
to a specific endpoint, you go
to a more aggregated level--
you can see whether,
for example,
traffic from application
A and application B
is going within the same region.
It is not going
out the internet.
You will be able to see
what are the traffic that
is, for example,
exiting internet
and what are the geolocations,
like that traffic is taking.
You will be as well
able to see what
is the traffic that
is going through a VPN
or through a interconnect
to your data center
so that you can
understand-- and as well you
can as well do filter
through in your application.
So you can see for your
different development
teams what is the paths and the
bandwidth that they are taking
and how the overall
distribution of the network
looks for your deployments.
Finally, we have as well more
maybe security-centric use
cases.
One of them-- its the
network forensics and audit
so that you are able to log
in your deployments what
is that traffic or the
connections that were allowed
or denied by your firewalls.
And then you're able to store
it for future processing.
So you will be
able, for example,
to ingest it into storage,
and come back in the future
and see at the specific point in
time what exactly was happening
in your network-- what was the
connections that were going on,
if you need to provide
proof of specific traffic
patterns, a specific
point in time,
what were the connections
that were allowed or denied.
You can just store it
in a storage in GCS,
in Google Cloud Storage, and
just come back for analysis.
And as well you are
able-- because we
are as well providing the
analysis in near real time,
you can see security
patterns, outliers
that you will be able to
visualize if you are concerned
about the specific
flows exiting,
for example, to the internet.
You're able to see those
signals in real time.
Let's talk specifically.
So that's all very good.
We have a bunch of use cases
that we need to solve for.
But really what does it mean?
Like, how do I
actually-- what are
the set of tools that I am
going to be using for those?
So to start with--
and I'm going to start
from maybe public facing
to endpoints that are
sitting in your VPCs.
We are going to provide with
internet facing apps load
balancer telemetry.
And then you can see the
utilization, the usage.
You can see the
request responses,
which codes are certain
requests as with you
can see latency
associated to your load
balancers, front end, back end.
You can as well then
go to your endpoints
in your VPC, VM instances, your
Google Kubernetes Engine notes.
And you can see with
VPC Flow Logs what
are the network flows
that were coming
in and out from a specific
VM instances endpoints.
And again you're able to get
those signals for every path.
Firewall logs will
allow you to obtain--
based on your configuration
of logging specific firewall
rules--
will allow you to
get all the attempts.
Firewall logs is not a
simple functionality.
We'll go more into the detail.
But it will give
you every connection
that it was attempted,
either allow or deny,
by a specific firewall
rule in which you
have chosen to configure login.
And finally, I'll
give you a little bit
of a teaser of something
that we are opening
to trusted testers, which is a
network topology visualization
tool, which it will give you
a topology of relationship
of your applications and
deployments and then metrics
that are associated
to specific paths.
So it is really getting the data
and giving you a little more
of a visual view of it.
Let's start with load
balancer telemetry.
So as I said, it
works for your HTTP,
HTTPS load balancers,
TCP/SSL proxy.
And it is a very
rich set of metrics.
It will give you signals
as well at the front end,
at the back end.
I'll do a little
bit of a demo so
that you can get a sense
of where is the information
and how you can
actually visualize it.
And it gives you latency
metrics, throughput metrics
for anything that it's really
sitting behind a load balancer
public facing.
VPC Flow Logs is something
that we've been working
very intense in the last year.
We went general
availability about I
think maybe a few weeks ago.
We are able to
provide the throughput
and latency in every path.
We're doing, again, near real
time, which is pretty unique.
We provide a lot of
information that you can ingest
through Stackdriver export.
You don't really need
to use Stackdriver
as a logging mechanism.
The export-- it could
allow you to go to Pub/Sub
or integrate with your [? CM ?]
or any partner of your choice.
And we're really work
with and integrate
with a lot of partners
so to provide you
a variety of different ways of
visualize and get your signals.
Finally, as I said, we're
providing the annotations.
One of our customers that
have been using VPC Flow Logs
was actually just
telling me last week
that they were able to log in
120 billion flows or records.
And then that they go to a speed
of processing of their signals
in the network over
100 times of what
they were able to do before.
So we're very excited to provide
the level of skill and speed
with VPC Flow Logs.
Firewall logs-- it's
currently in alpha.
And maybe some of you have
been already using it.
There is a very
specific difference
between firewall logs
and VPC Flow Logs.
Firewall logs is really more
security centric feature.
So we are not sampling.
We are logging every
attempted connection
whether it's deny or allow.
And the look and
feel and the way
you are exporting to
your tools are really
very similar as
the VPC Flow Logs.
And I'll show you a little bit.
But you can actually
export through Stackdriver
again through the
export capabilities.
You don't really need to use
Stackdriver as a logging.
But you can choose
to do that as well.
But you can export directly
through Pub/Sub, for example,
to the partner of your choice.
And we have as well annotations.
So specifically we add
the specific configuration
of the firewall rule at the
point in which the traffic was
either allow or deny so that
you can actually match it up,
the action that was
taken for the [INAUDIBLE]
against what that specific
firewall was looking
at the time that
action was taken.
And as well we aggregate
every five seconds.
We do that as well for ingress
and egress firewall rules.
In terms of exporting, I've
already mentioned a little bit
but we're just using
the same mechanism
so that you can actually
use the same exporting
mechanisms for your VPC Flow
Logs for your firewall logs.
And then you configure--
you're able to set up
filters of what you want to
send to either the Stackdriver
or what you actually
want to send to a storage
maybe for long-term
analysis if you want to keep
the data for coming back later.
Or you can send it to
Pub/Sub or to BigQuery
if you want to have your own
data processing analysis based
on the flow logs.
So a lot of choices.
And we do not really have any--
it is not really mandatory that
you ingest into Stackdriver
itself.
You can just directly
export to where you--
your choices.
And finally, as I
mentioned, I want
to encourage you to
go to DEV213 session.
We're going to be showing
there a little bit more
of what we're doing in terms of
network topology visualization.
And again we're opening
to our trusted testers
for getting your
data into the tool.
You will-- it looks
very similar than the--
if you've seen in the
keynote the Stackdriver Istio
visualization.
It's really the same
look and feel but more
from our network
perspective so that you
can see aggregated data,
more of the infrastructure,
rather than abstracting
the service visualization.
Now you can as well
filter in and out
in terms of zooming in
in specific applications.
But for example, you see traffic
from and to your data center,
from to internet, et cetera.
All right.
So will all that, I'm going
to do a quick walkthrough.
Let's see.
Can we switch to demo please?
SPEAKER 1: OK.
What's going on?
Is it on?
INES ENVID: It is on.
SPEAKER 1: It's sleeping.
[INAUDIBLE] taking
it to wake up.
INES ENVID: No.
Oh.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
I don't know how to wake it up.
INES ENVID: Do you want me to--
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, go ahead.
Yes.
Connect the line here.
INES ENVID: The
connection is not working.
OK.
SPEAKER 1: Here.
Yes.
It's working.
SPEAKER 2: It switched.
Sorry about that.
INES ENVID: No worries.
Oh cool.
All right.
Yay.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Got it working.
Yeah, kind of the workout
without showing you guys.
It's so cool.
All right.
So I have configured
some load balancers.
So you see my shopping
side load balancer.
You know it has a global VP.
It's accepting HTTP traffic.
Now I do have certain path
routes for my load balancer.
And those URLs have been
served by different backends.
So for example, I
have my browse, which
is served by
browse-backends, cart
is served by cart-backends,
and each of those as well.
Like for example, if I
go down browse-backends,
they have back ends points
in Asia, Europe, US.
So I'm able to see
certain information here
of what is the
usage and capacity.
But if I go to
monitoring, then I'm
going to be able to see
what is the RPS [INAUDIBLE]
back end and something
really cool like this.
What is the distribution
of my traffic being
served for a specific--
the connections from Asia
are being served by back ends
in Asia, connections
in North America
by my connection
in North America.
I can see how many
requests per second.
Additionally, I can
go to Stackdriver.
And then I see--
I have here, for example,
my cart-backends.
I can see a breakdown,
for example,
by back end [INAUDIBLE] I
can see what the latency is.
I can see the back end latency.
I can see on the front
end around three time.
I can see my request per
second for each of the zones.
So again, I've done
a breakdown per zone.
I can, for example,
choose "Match URL."
And then I'm going to
see my metrics now filter
by the specific URL.
So each of them is going
to be one URL that is
served by a set of back ends.
So this gives you a little
bit of sense of what
we have for load balancer.
It's a pretty rich
set of metrics.
For VPC Flow Logs,
for example, I have--
I guess I had it already
on the screen so I don't
need to walk through that.
But I have in a
network, a VPC network,
I have a specific subnets
in different regions.
And I have on for US central
subnet, VPC Flow Logs on for UN
central subnet and Europe west.
If I click, I'm able to actually
edit, say I want to have it on
or I want to have it off.
It actually also tells
me how much of the logs
that will be generated.
So you can estimate what's going
to be the volume associated
to the traffic.
So now if I look into what
the flow logs are actually
looking like, you can see.
Maybe zoom in a little bit.
So sorry, maybe zoom out so
you can see more in the screen.
You can see that
we are generating
records, the connection
five [? TOPEL. ?]
In this case, the destination
IP is a public IP.
The source IP's a private IP.
I can see the source
port on the protocols.
And then I can see
the destination.
It was public IP.
So then I can see the ASN and
the continent and the country
that it was generated.
I can see my metrics.
So I can see the roundtrip time.
I can see the number of packets
and then a bunch of annotations
related to the
instance and the VPCs.
And actually, it is
real time as you see.
And it's generating a
lot of streaming data.
So you can see it is really
loading all the records.
For federal rules, I have it
configured for one firewall--
just as an example, allow GCLV.
I am accepting traffic
from these source ranges
and from protocol 80.
So now if I actually
go to my view--
instead of actually
checking the VPC Flow Logs,
I check firewall.
And then I'm going to see--
for example, if
I click this one,
I'm going to see the
connection that I was allowed
and by which firewall
and actually get
the details of what that
specific firewall was again
at the point in time in
which this was configured.
The source range is what
you saw it was configured.
And it applies to
a set of instances.
And again, real time and it
gets updated as the traffic is
hitting those firewall rules.
Finally, again I'm just going
to show you a little bit of what
this is going to look like.
We are providing a
visualization tool,
which is-- this is open
to trusted servers.
And then what
you're going to see
is in the Stackdriver
topology you
will be able to load the
topology of your applications.
In this case, I have
a load balancer.
I do have traffic from
a specific region.
Like for example,
if I click here--
sorry, this is--
I'm going to be able
to see the metrics.
So for example-- so you can see.
You cannot see very well.
But you can see the
traffic that is generating
for the specific path--
in this case from Asia
to US Central back ends
in that load balancer.
And now with that,
I'm going to welcome
to stage Yuri, who's
the tech lead that's
behind a lot of the technology
that is powering our network
telemetry.
Please switch back
to presentation mode.
YURI SOLODKIN: Thank you, Ines.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, so before I
begin, I just wanted
to mention that there's
going to be a Q&A
session after this meeting.
And if you'll go to the
application of GCP Next,
from this session,
you should probably
see there a link to our Dory
where you can submit and vote
on questions.
So my name is Yuri.
I'm the tech lead
for VPC Flow Logs.
And I kind of wanted to give
you some engineering background
as to how we generate VPC Flow
Logs and what are the methods
that we are using.
And that's kind of to
give you a general feeling
as to the capabilities
of these two.
So to generate VPC Flow Logs, we
start by sampling connections.
We sample packet headers
and all connections
coming through and from a VM.
And by sampling
packet headers we
are able to monitor
connection behavior over time.
If you have on-prem
setups, you're
probably familiar with tools
such as NetFlow and sFlow,
which have a very
similar approach.
So from every packet
that we sample,
we extract IPs,
ports, and protocol
in order to uniquely
identify a connection.
We sample as close
to the VM as possible
in order to ensure that we are
seeing the same IPs addresses
as specified by the VM.
And this ensures
us that we will be
able to correlate VPC Flow
Logs with other data sources
that you might have--
for example, if
you're running agents
on your VM to collect
the same type of data.
Every five seconds we
combine all of the headers
that we've seen for
each connection.
And by keeping track
of sequence numbers
we are able to estimate packet
count on the connection.
By looking at the payload size
we are calculating throughput.
And for TCP connections where
enough packets were captured,
we are able to
correlate [INAUDIBLE]
time stamps to estimate RTT as
experienced by the connection.
So gathering information
is one thing.
But making sure that it's
accurate is kind of difficult.
So for network monitoring
tools, accuracy
is of the highest importance.
To make sure that we
have high accuracy,
we try to set our sampling rate
to the highest value possible.
To do that we do not just
set a constant sampling rate.
But we adjust our
sampling rate in real time
to the highest value
possible without exceeding
set resources.
This sampling rate is
being captured per packet
to make sure that we are
compensating correctly
for the packets
that we do not see.
Furthermore, we then
measure the accuracy
of our system against a
separate [INAUDIBLE] system
just to make sure that our
pipeline is not only available
but that its accuracy is intact.
Although IPs and ports are
the backbone of our reports,
it's not necessarily the
most useful identifiers
for VPC Flow Logs.
Sometimes when you look
at connections of VMs,
for example, that
no longer exist
or you look at the
IP addresses that
do not belong to
your network, those
are hard to make sense of.
In order to tackle that
problem while we process
the data in real time,
we combine the data
with metadata from your project.
And we are able to annotate GCP
endpoints with VM identifiers,
VPC identifiers.
And for external
endpoints, we are
able to annotate geolocation
such as country, city,
and region, which enables
you to search and filter
VPC Flow Logs by those fields.
So for example, if you're
interested in seeing
traffic between two
VMs, you can do that.
Or if you're interested
in seeing traffic
from a certain region
to a certain country,
you can do that as well.
So there are a lot of use
cases for network monitoring
tools, many of which
require data that is fresh.
One of those use cases--
one that is close to my heart--
is debugging
large-scale systems.
And our collection system
was built with that in mind.
So after collecting
data for five seconds,
we spend additional four
second processing this data.
And we assure those quick
times by making sure
that our pipeline is
distributed in all cloud zones
so that the data
is being processed
near where it was sampled.
Then after additional
10 seconds,
this data is available
for your use.
So if you're running a
scenario on your network,
you're able to see relevant
VPC Flow Logs for this scenario
in under 20 seconds
from when it happened.
Now every GCP project is unique.
Some projects are small
and have very few VMs,
but some projects are large and
have very complicated networks.
Our pipeline
currently is already
handling a very large
portion of GCP traffic--
those belonging to early
adopters of VCP Flow
Logs and beta users.
So the amount of VPC
Flow Logs currently
amounts to millions
of records per second.
And we experience no performance
impact on user compute
or network resources.
So you should not
hesitate enabling
VCP Flow Logs for your network.
Keep in mind that
enabling those logs
may result in substantial
amount of traffic.
But BigQuery, cloud
logging, and Pub/Sub
are provisioned to handle them
if you choose to use them.
So as long as you
can ingest this data,
we are able to provide it.
The other project our team is
working on is firewall logging.
So firewall logging is collected
differently than VPC Flow Logs,
because the use cases
for firewall logging
are a bit different than
those of VPC Flow Logs.
For VPC Flow Logs,
we wanted to ensure
that our users are
able to monitor
connection behavior over time.
For firewall logging, the
existence of the connection
is more important
than its behavior.
So firewall logs are
generated per firewall event.
So every time the
connection is created
or a connection is denied, a
relevant plug will be created.
To do so, we keep a
connection table for every VM.
And every time we add the
new connection to the table,
we will generate
a firewall rule--
firewall log.
For connections
that were denied,
we will report each
time that a connection
was attempted in order to
enable security use cases.
By taking this approach,
we are able to guarantee
with higher confidence
that we will report
on every relevant connection.
So firewall logs-- very
similar to VPC Flow Logs--
are reported in near
real time, which
means that after a
connection is created
you are able to see a relevant
log in just a few seconds.
We guarantee that
we can capture up
to 100 connections per
second for every core that
is provisioned for your VM.
And we do that without
any performance impact
on your compute resources.
Firewall logs, just
as VPC Flow Logs,
are annotated in real time with
metadata from your project.
And in addition to annotating
VM instances and geolocations,
we also combine those logs
with relevant firewall rules
so that you can easily use them.
Thank you.
With that, I'm
going to introduce
Vineet, who's going to talk
about our partner ecosystem.
[APPLAUSE]
VINEET BHAN: Thank you, Yuri.
My name is Vineet Bhan.
I lead security partnerships
for Google Cloud.
So I work with third
party security companies.
So in addition to what
Ines and Yuri explain
in terms of technology
that Google has built,
we also work very closely with
the leading security companies
and logging and
monitoring companies
to bring solutions to
you that are innovative
as well as for solutions that
are you currently using on-prem
or in your private
cloud deployments.
You can use the same solutions
in Google Cloud as well.
So I'll explain the
different aspects
that will be relevant
as you're thinking
about logging and monitoring.
So in terms of
partner solutions,
I will not cover
all of them today.
I will just cover
some of the categories
and mention only some
of the partner names.
There is a lot going
on with many partners.
We don't have enough
to cover everybody.
So generally
speaking, if you think
about which categories of
partners would be relevant,
the first and foremost
would be the SIEM vendors.
So we have companies like
Sumo Logic and Splunk,
who have prebuilt GCP apps.
So it will be very easy
for you to ingest--
use those apps, ingest the data,
and use the visualization tools
that you're very
comfortable with.
So the same vendors would
be obviously something
you should be looking at.
The next generation
firewall partners
that we have-- obviously
when the traffic is flowing
through the next gen firewalls,
they have a lot of visibility
into their traffic.
So their visualization tools
are very relevant as well.
I'll explain couple of
examples there as well.
The third category
is the compliance
vendors, which
are more new, born
in the cloud kind of
companies like RedLock, Dome9.
And how they are integrating
with VPC Flow Logs
should give you very good
visualization solutions
and security on top of that.
So I'll explain couple of
examples there as well.
So there are a broad category
of partners that you can look at
to give you the visibility as
well as more security analytics
on top of that.
So if you just double click on
the first category within SIEM
partners--
Splunk and Sumo Logic are
the ones that I mentioned.
This is a picture of a
Sumo Logic VPC app that
was released very recently.
And it gives you
great visibility
and on the traffic
profile as well as
their kind of
integrations they have
done with Stackdriver and other
pieces of Google services.
They'll get near real-time
dashboards that you can use.
So these are
prebuilt dashboards.
You can go to Sumo Logic,
download them, ingest the data,
and the visualizations already
exist, so very easy to leverage
them.
Similarly this is an
example of a Sumo Logic app
they have built for
firewall logging.
So the great innovation
that Ines and Yuri
shared about all the data
that we are collecting,
a prebuilt app from
Sumo Logic as an example
could be a great place
to ingest that data
and visualize it in
a very easy manner.
The next category of partners
are the next gen firewall
partners that we mentioned.
So this is Palo Alto Networks.
We have been working with Palo
Alto team for a long time.
So this is kind of
the integration work
we have been doing with them.
So all the traffic is flowing
through Palo Alto Networks.
In this case, the customer
wants to use their firewall.
So all the rich data that
they are collecting and adding
to the data that
they see would be
visible through
their dashboards.
So panorama, for
example, can also
correlate the different
things that you are seeing--
the Palo Alto
firewall is seeing.
So if you're using a Palo Alto
firewall in addition to a SIEM,
you could obviously use the
Palo Alto interfaces as well.
Another example is Check
Point, another firewall partner
that we have.
In addition to the
logging data, you
can also look at how
they detect threats
and how they're doing an
anomaly detection on top
of just looking at flow.
So this is another
example of existing tools
that you may be comfortable
leveraging on-prem.
Same tools available
in GCP as well.
So the third category of
partners I wanted to mention
was the compliance partners.
You guys may have worked
with some of them.
In this case, this
is the RedLock.
We've been working
closely with them as well.
They have another integration
into VPC Flow Log.
So the graph that
you see on the chart
is the VPC Flow
Log implementation
and the visualizations they
have built on top of it.
So in addition to
the visualization,
they also do things
like detecting
cryptomining and
other security on top
of the data they're collecting.
So these are very good tools
as well to take a look out
as you are thinking about how
do I visualize and monitor
the network that I'm building.
So another example
in that category
is Dome9, a partner for
more than a year for us,
have done similar
flow log integrations.
So in their example
for example, you
can see the traffic that you're
receiving from malicious IPs.
So they have an IP
reputation list.
So bad IPs sending
traffic to your VPC--
you can easily visualize
what's going on.
So that's just kind
of a few partner
examples I wanted to give.
In addition to that,
there are some products
that Google has built
that some of you
may have heard about-- the
Cloud Security Command Center.
So this was announced
in the March time frame.
It's a visualization framework
that gives you visibility
into the services that
you're running on GCP,
provides interesting
security insights.
And it's a flexible
platform where
you can change the visualization
based on your needs.
So this is a great
platform to leverage
that Google has built to see
the visualization of all the--
and get all the telemetry
and measuring and bit
logging in one place.
So very interesting aspect
of the Command Center
is it ingests data
from Google services.
So you can have all the
data that Google can see.
In addition, you also have
partner integrations there.
So you could have the
partners that I mentioned--
Palo Alto Network,
Dome9, RedLock.
You can have all the data,
the security signaling
they are seeing also pushed
to the Command Center.
So Command Center becomes
your one dashboard
to look at the third
party products as well
as Google products and get one
place of getting all the data.
And we will continue to
work with these partners,
invest more, and move towards
automating once the data is
visualized, how do we help you
kind of solve those problems,
react to certain threats?
So we will continue to
work with these partners
to make security monitoring
easier and easier.
So towards the end, we have
done all these integrations.
I wanted to share
some of the things
that we are hearing from
partners very similar to what
Ines and Yuri mentioned.
What people are
really liking about,
what you should think about is
the near real-time capabilities
of seeing it at Google
interfaces or partner
interfaces.
We believe it's kind of very
important and differentiated
for us and not having to
worry about how much logging
resources or how much
resources we're logging consume
is also very helpful as well
as the ASN and other things
that we are pending.
So I think customers have
received it very well.
We're getting very positive
feedback, looking forward
to hearing more from
you guys as well,
and continue to build
more and more products.
[MUSIC PLAYING]